President Trump says a lot of stuff
about Puerto Rico gets him in trouble
plus craziness over at Google and John
Kerry carrying out collusion with the
Iranians we'll get to all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is ben shapiro show
[Music]
one of the features behind the scenes of
the show that you never see is that
every morning Alex one of our producers
picks out a great clip from a movie to
cheer me up before the show and today he
picked out some Shakespeare and so we
were watching a little bit of Henry the
fifth and then I looked at today's news
and I went oh god and we'll get to all
of today's news because yeah yeah
everything's stupid as per our usual
arrangement everything is quite stupid
first let's talk about gold let's talk
about the fact that we have a twenty one
trillion dollar national debt money we
owe other countries as well as our own
Treasury it's greater than the entire
economic output of the United States if
your entire life savings is tied to the
US dollar you should ask yourself what
happens if the government decides to
inflate its way out of all of this debt
well you can hedge against inflation and
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is a safe haven
against uncertainty my savings plan is
diversified and yours should be -
doesn't mean put all your money in gold
means put a little bit of your money in
precious metals the company I'd trust
with precious metal purchases Birch gold
group and right now thanks to a
little-known IRS tax law you can even
move that IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold or silver
which is perfect for people who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty look back historically when
bottom falls out of everything else gold
is always worth something Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau so
what's your plan you all know about
Birch gold free information kit but for
a limited time qualified purchases can
earn up to an additional 10 grand in
precious metals for free through
September 30th to find out if your
purchase will qualify contact Birch gold
right now go to birchgold.com slash Bend
speak to a Birch gold representative
mentioned I sent you that's
birchgold.com slash been do it now the
offer only runs until September 30th
terms limitations apply ask your sales
representative for details all right so
we begin today with the President of the
United States who has great economic
news who's facing down a hurricane that
is going to make landfall very shortly
who is in the midst of what could be a
decent news cycle plus a crisis that
requires some presidential leadership
so naturally the president took to
Twitter to tweet about hurricane Maria
which happened like a year and a half
ago because that's what we do around
here we just do stupid crap like on a
routine basis that's pretty much all we
do so the media have decided to cover
anew the death toll from Puerto Rico and
this is happening obviously in the
run-up to Hurricane Florence which is
set to make landfall in the next 48
hours or so
and the President of the United States
is very angry watching the media cover
the death toll from Hurricane Maria
which was of course the major hurricane
that hit Puerto Rico about a year and a
half ago and the media been covering
particularly the Puerto Rican
government's revised death toll which
now stands at two thousand nine hundred
and seventy five now you remember
originally the stated death toll was
something like six to 18 and everybody
said well that's way too low that's not
real and then it turns out that it kept
being revised upward and upward and
upward well president Trump decided that
he needed to tweet about that and this
is just a foolish move on every level
first of all if you want to discuss the
level of the disaster response discuss
the level of the disaster response if
you want to talk about the vagary of the
numbers of estimated dead there's a way
to do that too
the way to do that is not to suggest
that only six people died in the
hurricane because six people clearly did
not die in the hurricane it was a lot
more people than that and there's an
enormous amount of variation in the
estimates for death from hurricane it
shall explain in just a second but here
is what President Trump tweeted this
morning obviously eating the news cycle
all day even though we now have great
economic news even though again the
president's leadership is necessary with
regard to the response to Hurricane
Florence the president decides it is
deeply necessary to jump into a
conspiracy theory by which the media
have promulgated a statistic that is
outright false here's what the president
says quote 3,000 people did not die in
the two hurricanes that hit Puerto Rico
when I left the island after the storm
it hit they had anywhere from 6 to 18
deaths as time went by it did not go up
by much then a long time later they
started to report really large numbers
like 3,000 this was done by the
Democrats in order to make me look as
bad as possible when I was successfully
raising billions of dollars to help
rebuild barbarika if a person died for
any reason like oh the age just add the
man to the list
bad politics I love Puerto Rico
exclamation point
well one way to show you don't love
Porto Rico is by suggesting only six
people by that's probably not a very
good idea and while the president is not
wrong to show that to suggest that there
is vagary to the statistics he's
certainly wrong to suggest that only 20
people died or that the count of dead
basically stopped the minute that he
left Puerto Rico now let's get into the
actual statistics with regard to the
number of people who died in poor
Rico first the president yesterday was
bragging about Puerto Rico saying that
that Puerto Rico was a tremendous
success by the federal government I mean
this is always a mistake it's always a
mistake when the federal government
proclaims how well they've done on a
project like this George W Bush of
course famously said that his head of
FEMA Ron Brown had done a heck of a job
and that basically finished his
presidency in 2006 after Hurricane
Katrina I mean who's basically a lame
duck from there on in it was a horrible
move President Trump just a couple of
days ago praised his successes in Puerto
Rico and that of course generated this
whole new round of headlines Puerto Rico
was actually our toughest one of all
because it's an island so you didn't you
can't truck things onto it everything's
by boat we moved to hospital in to
Puerto Rico a tremendous military
hospital in the form of a ship you know
that and I actually think it was one of
the best jobs that's ever been done with
respect to what this is all about
I think the Puerto Rico was an
incredible unsung success okay so just
fantastic stuff you know he says that in
the San Juan mayor who is responsible by
the way for an enormous amount of
catastrophic suffering in Puerto Rico
the Puerto Rican government is
responsible for the vast majority of
suffering on the island of Puerto Rico
although the federal government may have
botched the response they did not botch
it to the extent that the Puerto Rican
government botched it there's no
question about this for example here's
some video showing water sitting on an
abandoned tarmac and people are dying of
dehydration in Puerto Rico people can't
find potable water anywhere CNN covered
this yesterday literally millions and
millions something like 40 million
bottles of water sitting on an abandoned
tarmac 38 million bottles of water or 10
for every resident of Puerto Rico or so
just sitting there baking in the Sun
apparently it's the FEMA started
delivering to that airstrip back in the
fall October or November or so they
didn't start distributing it until May
and then some residents complained of a
foul odor and taste
okay so just spectacular job by
everybody involved including the local
government the San Juan mayor of course
trying to shift the blame in the same
way that the mayor of New Orleans Ray
Nagin tried to shift the blame to the
federal government and the governor of
Louisiana who I believe is Kathleen
Blanco at the time tried to shift all
the responsibility the federal
government's are
Catrina now the Puerto Rican government
is attempting to do the same to the feds
it's pretty obvious however that the
local government really botched this one
here's what the San Juan mayor had to
say of course blasting President Trump
well I think the president statement is
despicable
it just goes to the lack of
understanding of reality that he has if
he thinks that the death of 3,000 people
is the best he really doesn't know what
this was all about this was never about
politics he's talking about on song
phrase well you know nobody's singing
his praises so I really don't know where
the president gets the nerve to call
this a success story
okay so everybody does have an interest
in shifting the blame however the way to
fight this is by suggesting that the
federal government did its job the local
government did not do its job which i
think is actually a pretty fair argument
from the evidence that is on the table
instead for the president to start
tweeting out about how 3,000 people are
not actually dead like what happened to
them were they raptured and what
happened out were they just really just
sort of they're up and walking around
but we sort of yet just didn't count
them correctly here's the problem when
you're trying to come up with a death
estimate from a hurricane there are two
major issues one is that there are a lot
of people who whose bodies are just
missing like you don't actually know
where they are because of the hurricane
because of natural disasters this is
true in every natural disaster and to
it's difficult to actually attribute a
death to the hurricane let's say that
for example there's a hospital and the
hospital's power is knocked out by the
hurricane and they're a bunch of sick
people in the hospital and a bunch of
those sick people died did those people
die because they were going to die
anyway or did they die because the
hurricane knocked out the power and then
the government didn't do its job in
restoring the power so if they don't get
potable water for example if there are
38 million bottles of water sitting on
an abandoned tarmac in Puerto Rico and
that water doesn't get to people and
people die of dehydration three months
after the event is that due to the is
that due to the hurricane or is that due
to government malfeasance how do you
actually chalk up these statistics and
this isn't just me saying this in some
sort of a defense of the president these
sort of uncertainties do exist in
estimates with or without regard to what
the hurricane is so for example
Hurricane Katrina in 2015 Carl B Alec of
538 pointed out quote we still don't
know how many people died because of
Katrina here's what he wrote he said by
its own admission Bowie Louisiana never
finished counting the dead its last news
release on the
topic from February 2006 put the
statewide toll at 1103 three months
later it added hundreds of state
residents who died in other states 30
months after that in August 2006
Louisiana counted one thousand four
hundred sixty four victims with a
hundred and thirty five people still
missing today in 2015 when asked about
the Louisiana death total the Health
Department cites a 2008 study that
reviewed death certificates and
concluded there were nine hundred eighty
six victims but that study said the
total could actually be fifty percent
higher if deaths possibly linked to the
storm are included this is one of the
major questions do you just include
direct deaths meaning somebody was swept
up in the hurricane and died or
somebody's house blew over and they were
crushed or did you include indirect
deaths like the dehydration case again
this from 538 direct deaths are those
that occur from drowning or an injury
sustained during a storm or post storm
flooding while indirect deaths occur
from some other cause that might be
linked to the storm such as an inability
to access medical care to treat an
illness after Katrina government
counters in Louisiana chose to include
indirect deaths based on an arbitrary
cutoff people who are evacuated from New
Orleans and died after October 1st were
not included while those who died before
were the authors of the 2008 study that
counted 986 Louisiana deaths took a
different approach counting only deaths
that could be directly attributed to the
storm so it is not clear at all how many
people even died in Hurricane Katrina so
now fast forward to to Hurricane Maria
and president Trump back in May of this
year he started trotting out these
statistics that are clearly not true he
said 16 people very died in Hurricane
Maria he's at 16 people certified 16
people versus in the thousands you can
be very proud of all your people all of
our people working together 16 versus
literally thousands of people but in
reality thousands of people died in
Hurricane Maria hey it's only a question
as to how many thousands of people died
here is governor Ricardo Rosello back a
few months ago they announced that they
had increased the death toll to near
3,000 and there's another study that
suggested the death toll is actually
near 5,000 here is the governor on CNN
being grilled over the statistics the
way it's it's taken care when he got to
it was those related to the storm
immediately after the storm once we
realized that that was a faulty protocol
we called upon the market institute
George
Chintan so that they can revise it and
do it properly and do it scientifically
so it's taken time yeah no doubt about
it but the number is Eagle on your
website I mean he sure that all of the
data I'm sorry to interrupt but just to
be clear you're saying that that number
on your website the official death toll
is not accurate well we've never
expected that it was accurate that's why
we always said that it was gonna be
higher and that we gave the task to
George Washington University so that
they can study it and that they could
arrive at a number so I'm gonna explain
how they came up with this statistic and
why President Trump is wrong despite all
the vagary of this and why it's
politically in apps for him to approach
this issue at all frankly but first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
when we talk about sleep you talk you
think about a lot of things you think
about you know the quality of the light
in your room you may think about the
quality of your mattress which is
certainly something we're thinking about
but you should really be thinking as
well about your sheets are your sheets
actually comfortable I know you don't
think about your sheets very much you
just got a cheap pair down at the local
retail outlet and even sleeping on those
you like oh they're probably fine
they're not fine they're probably
garbage instead you should be sleeping
on bull and branch sheets because
everything bull and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means these
sheets start out supersoft they get even
softer over time and you can buy
directly from bull and branch so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in the store bull and branches
are only a couple hundred bucks and
before you say that sounds expensive
it isn't considering that you're
sleeping on them every night and they're
so comfortable that actually got rid of
all the other sheets in my house once we
started using ball and branch it's
difficult for me to sleep on sheets of
lower quality now so bull and branch has
indeed spoiled my sleep quality on
nights when I'm sleeping not in bowling
branch bow and branch sheets are just
that good
everybody whom trot loves bull and
branch sheets everybody who tries them
loves them which is why they have
thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep I'm pulling
bran sheets shipping is free and you can
try them for free for 30 nights meaning
if you don't love them send them back
for a refund so there's really nothing
to lose I doubt you're gonna want to
send them back there's no risk no reason
not to give them a try to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets they
go from 200 150 at bow and branch calm
promo code Ben that's bull and branch
calm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets Bo LLM branch comm promo
code Ben use that promo code Ben's let
them know that I sent you and also so
that you can get that special deal so
how exactly did they come up with this
3,000 number
well as you heard ricardo rosado who's
the Governor of Puerto Rico he basically
outsourced the study to George
Washington University and what they did
is they compared excess deaths over the
normal death rate at this particular
time of year they said quote our excess
mortality study analyzed past mortality
patterns mortality registration and
population census data from 2010 to 2017
in order to predict the expected
mortality if Hurricane Maria had not
occurred that's the predicted mortality
and compared that to the actual deaths
that did occur which were the observed
mortality now the problem there is that
maybe it was a year when there are going
to be an inordinate number of deaths
anyway we don't actually have the names
of the people so can you count somebody
is dead if you never find their name out
of these people who existed or did not
exist this is why there's inherent
vagary and that's why the numbers really
swing pretty wildly here there was a
study that came out last year not from
George Washington that put the range of
estimates anywhere from 900 people dead
to 8,000 people dead was from Harvard as
huge range and people said that's an
insane range how are we even supposed to
take that seriously the George
Washington University study estimated
total excess mortality at two thousand
nine hundred seventy five the Puerto
Rican government adopted that number
this year the Puerto Rican government
had already increased its body count to
nearly 1500 in early September
estimating deaths in the four months
after the storm but Lynn Goldman who's
the Dean of the university's Milken
Institute of Public Health admitted
quote among all the deaths that occurred
which were them were related to Maria
which of them would not have occurred if
it hadn't been for the storm were not
able to say that now so there is
vagueness there are a bunch of different
estimates the New York Times estimated a
thousand deaths occurred after Maria the
the medical journal JAMA the Journal of
American medicine estimated between a
thousand and thirteen hundred people
died in connection with the storm and
again there was that Harvard University
study that put the estimate anywhere
from 800 to 8,500 which is a huge range
but was it six people was it 18 people
know it wasn't six or 18 people it was
certainly hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of people and in fact the
president is reopening this wound by
suggesting the only reason people are
talking about these deaths is to get him
politically is a huge mistake it's a
huge political mistake especially
because the President of the United
States has been particularly critical
over the course of his career of other
people's handling of hurricanes here is
what he tweeted after Hurricane sandy
quote the federal government has handled
Sandy worse than Katrina there is
no excuse why people don't have
electricity or fuel yet about 285 people
died in Hurricane sandy and it is
important to note the initial estimate
was 26 dead the final estimate was like
300 dead in hurricane sandy so the
estimates always rise from beginning for
the President to use that original
estimate is statistically illiterate and
it's also politically foolish given the
fact that the president has a pretty
good argument about the local government
botching the job rather than the federal
government botching the job now it just
looks like he's insensitive now it just
looks like he doesn't care and the only
reason that he cares about the fallout
from these particular issues is for his
own political survival which looks gross
in any case involving death we on the
right ripped president obama up and down
for not taking seriously enough the
deaths in benghazi those four people it
looks really bad when the President of
the United States doesn't look like he's
taking serious of the deaths of what has
to be hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of people it's just it's
it's really it's one of the worst things
he's ever tweeted frankly it's really
really bad okay so in just a second
I want to talk about the mainstream
media and and Google so Google Breitbart
got a hold of and I'm not sure how they
did they got a hold of tape from Google
right after the election and the tape
from Google right after the election is
pretty telling because remember all of
these major media companies have
essentially suggested there is no bias
at these companies now just because
people at a particular company are
politically biased does not mean that
necessarily their product is biased but
when you are talking about the art of
coming up with a search engine that
benefits certain results at the expense
of other results you do have to ask
questions as to how exactly those
algorithms are created now I have
friends who work for Google and these
are folks who work hard every day try
and create algorithms that are more
responsive to market conditions but
there's no question that Google
manipulates its data on a pretty regular
basis they've done this for example with
regard to China where they've cut off
certain search results at the behest of
the government why couldn't Google do
that on behalf of various other
political causes the answer is they
certainly could and they have in the
past we reported here on this program I
think is based on a Washington Examiner
report if I'm not mistaken a Daily
Caller report I can remember I don't
want to miss a tribute it
there's there's a report that Google had
been attaching fact checks from
left-wing sources to sources like Daily
wire Daily Caller Washington Examiner
but had done no such thing for sources
on the
left Google had to correct it so in
other words when you're creating an
algorithm it's garbage in garbage out if
you start with a particular premise and
the premise is politically biased you're
gonna end up with a result that is also
politically biased it's hard to think
that that's not what's been happening
but these major tech companies like
Google particularly in the aftermath of
some of the ridiculous things that are
being said at this particular meeting
right after the election so they held a
company-wide meeting of kind of top
executives and team leaders where
everybody vented about President Trump
and this tape finally broke over at
Breitbart the vice president for global
affairs Kent Walker went off on on
president Trump suggesting that Google
which their their their their slogan was
something like don't be evil but by be
evil they basically mean be conservative
here is them ripping into everyone who
voted for President Trump is the VP of
global affairs we do think that history
is on our side in a profound and an
important way I would say that the moral
arc of history is long but it bends
toward progress and out of progress
comes rising living standards and better
healthcare and ultimately the ability to
transcend those forces of tribalism and
yes weeds toward justice well it may be
that the internet and globalization were
part of the cause of this problem we
were also fundamentally an essential
part of the solution to this problem so
you can see the lamentation you can see
the wailing and the gnashing of teeth
people rending their garments and
putting sack cloth and ashes on and it
wasn't just Kent Walker was also Sergey
Brin who's the co-founder of Google who
said he was deeply offended by president
Trump's election and all these people
can have their political point of view
but if you think that this doesn't bleed
into the product it's very difficult to
imagine that and it's going to again
underscore the level of distrust
conservatives have for a lot of these
major tech companies as an immigrant and
a refugee I certainly find the selection
deeply offensive and I know many of you
do too
and and I think it's a very stressful
time and it conflicts with many of our
values okay so yeah there he is Sergey
Brin basically saying that Google's
values have been overridden by President
Trump why would anybody on the right be
suspicious of how these tech companies
run their business and then this is the
best part this this
nerd in the audience gets up and starts
talking about white privilege while
learning the backpack which is always
good luck and a bunch of Google
executives start applauding him for
talking about white privilege and a
company that is I believe universally
won by white people so here is here is
the the Google execs applauding Rando
for shouting about white privilege
speaking to white men there is an
opportunity for you right now to
understand your privilege in the society
take the opportunity to go through the
bias busting training read about
privilege read about the real history of
oppression in our country and tomorrow
night watch 13th the movie that is here
if you can't watch it here watch it on
Netflix discuss the issues you are
passionate about during Thanksgiving
dinner and don't back down and laugh it
off when you hear the voice of
oppression speak through metaphors and I
promise to do this wow so much caroling
so much harrowing I mean just that look
at the heroism on that stage these are
the same people who caved under knuckled
under to the Chinese government when the
Chinese government was trying to foster
turn in own country by preventing
certain search results look at that I
mean we have to fight white privilege in
the United States say a bunch of white
guys on the stage just really really
amazing stuff from Google again the
elites in this country are driving
people into a state of madness because
they believe that they are being passed
over in favor of particular values that
are held by a group of people who are
out of touch with everyday Americans how
to talk a little bit more about that in
just one second but first let's talk
about the way that you take care of your
company legally you know the same time
is money well it is certainly true
especially when you run your own
business but running a successful
business involves taxes contracts a
whole lot of fine print things that eat
up a lot of your time well the way that
you can avoid this is by turning to
LegalZoom over the last 17 years more
than a million Americans have used Legal
Zoom to help launch their businesses and
that is only the beginning Legal Zoom
also has a network of independent
attorneys tax professionals they can
provide you with the advice you need to
get through the daily grind of running
your business and the best part is you
don't have to worry about driving to
anyone's office or being billed by the
hour
because Legal Zoom is not a law firm so
you can count on Legal Zoom to provide
those business resources you need and
service that fits into your schedule
again invest your time and money into
growing your business
let LegalZoom take care of the rest go
to legalzoom.com right now use code ben
at checkout for special savings I've
known about Legal Zoom I've used legals
in myself for years before they were an
advertiser
on the program they really do terrific
work and now the fact that they have
this network of independent attorneys
and tax professionals means they've
expanded their services beyond the stuff
they used to do which was basically just
wills and trusts before and foreign
contracts now they've actually got the
advice you need go over to legalzoom.com
use promo code been at checkout for
special savings again legalzoom.com use
that special code men LegalZoom is where
life meets legal okay so one of the
things that that I think is so
alienating about what you saw there from
Google and and the Google leadership is
this feeling of a gap between the elites
who control the way we think and
everybody else in the country who is
sick and tired of being told what to do
and I think people are getting tired of
the feeling that the system is rigged
not just on the technological level but
also on the governmental level on the
level of of pushing particular thought I
think that people are getting very
uptight with that I think it also plays
into the Democrats agenda of free
college tuition so there's been a lot of
talk lately about free college tuition
virtually every major Democrat in the
country is pushing free college tuition
this is not about increasing people's
income trajectory this is the lie they
keep saying that we need free college
tuition in order to increase people's
income trajectory the reality is that
the reason that Democrats keep pushing
in the free college tuition is because
they want everyone to be part of this
thought contingent that is pushed on
college campuses they want people put
into a mill of leftist thought and
brought out the other end as good little
liberals who are who are dependent on
government largesse and believe the
government can solve all of our problems
and the the lie is that college is going
to make you rich and it's going to make
you wealthy and the truth is that
college is gonna put you in a serious
amount of debt or way several years of
your life if you don't major in the
right thing there's very little evidence
to suggest that a college degree alone
is likely to raise a given person's
income because college educated people
do outturn non-college educated people
but that's largely because there's an IQ
gap between people who go to college and
people who don't go to college I mean
just to put this as bluntly as possible
people go to college on average have a
higher IQ than people who do not go to
college on average that doesn't mean
everyone who doesn't go to college is
stupid obviously there are a lot of high
school graduates who didn't graduate
college who are incredibly smart Bill
Gates didn't graduate college Jeremy
boring who's that my who's the CEO of
this company did not graduate from
college Jeremy's a really smart guy but
on average the reason that you see a gap
between college graduates and non
college graduates is because again on
average people graduate from college
tend to be higher IQ than people who do
not graduate from college but that does
not mean that college makes you smarter
it means that college is a sorting
mechanism Oren cast of Manhattan
Institute points out the vast majority
of Community College enrollees drop out
fewer than 60 percent of students
complete degrees with even six years at
the schools where they first enroll
that's at four-year colleges according
to the Federal Reserve Bank of New York
four in ten recent graduates work
non-degree requiring jobs that means
they're a bunch of people who are
working at coffee bean who graduated
from college today actually have to go
to college to work at coffee bean of
course not
hey Oren Cass points out the bottom half
of the earnings distribution for college
grads not just enrollees but graduates
sits lower than the top half of earnings
distribution for those with only a high
school education in other words higher
earning high school graduates do better
than lower earning college graduates
which makes a lot of sense if you're the
higher earning high school graduate
chances are you are pretty high IQ guy
who didn't go to huh who didn't go to
college and if you are a lower earning
college graduate chances are pretty good
that you were lower IQ college graduate
who didn't actually have to go to
college to work the job that you're
working right now but the left keeps
pushing everybody into college why are
they pushing everybody into college
because they keep lying about the idea
that if you go to college you're gonna
be rich coming out but it really does
depend on major in a pretty significant
way here are the top ten earning majors
among graduates according to the Census
Bureau and the American Community Survey
petroleum engineering pharmaceutical
science and administration metallurgical
engineering mining and mineral
engineering chemical engineering
Electrical Engineering aerospace
engineering mechanical engineering
Computer Engineering and finally
geological and geophysical engineering
you notice anything in common about all
those majors yes it's the word
engineering it turns out when you major
in something practical because you're a
smart person who's majoring in a
marketable commodity you're gonna make
money coming out of college now here are
the top ten lowest earning College
graduating majors hey ready for this
here we go
Family and Consumer Science drama and
theatre arts shocker elementary
education theology Visual and Performing
Arts teacher education Social Work
studio arts Human Services and commune
organization and early childhood
education in other words the liberal
arts or at UCLA as we call them the
North Campus majors those people make
less money than the people than the
money people are making in engineering
but the free college degree crowd want
everybody to go to college and major in
drama and theater arts and teacher
education and early childhood education
they don't urge everybody to go into
engineering they're not urging everybody
to go into a useful major in fact that's
what government loans do government
loans are specifically there to allow
you to major in useless crap that is
what government loans are therefore
because let's say that you're a high
school graduate and let's say you got
1,300 on your SATs you a decent score
you can go to a good school the 1,300
SAT and let's say you have a choice
between mechanical engineering and drama
for some reason you're into both of
those so you decide you know what I like
drama better about mechanical
engineering looks like more of a career
path let's say that only private banks
only private lenders we're willing to
actually give you a loan no one would
give you a loan to go into drama and
theater arts no one you would not be
able to get a loan for that because a
college degree is not collateral it's
not like a mortgage or that where the
bank actually just gives you a loan
against the value of your house there's
no loan against the value of your
college degree it's them betting on
whether you're going to be successful
career wise enough for them to pay you
back so you would never bet on a drama
major you would bet on an engineering
major if you are a bank by two feet of
the federal government you don't make
that bet if you're the federal
government it doesn't matter what you
major it if you're the federal
government then what difference does it
make whether you major in drama and
theatre arts or whether you major in
mechanical engineering which means that
the government is subsidizing people to
major in precisely the majors that are
least likely to earn you money when you
get out of college okay here's the
reason this matters because this
suggests that Democrats when they're
talking about free college tuition are
not actually talking about increasing
income trajectory what they're actually
talking about is shoveling people into
college to major in things that don't
actually earn coming out the other side
now why would they do that two reasons
one it artificially lowers the the
unemployment rate because you have an
enormous number of people who are now
quote-unquote in the education system so
they don't actually have to have jobs
and number two it shovels an enormous
quantity of cash to a bunch of their
political allies because here's the
dirty little secret all the majors that
actually earn are less
biased than the majors that don't earn
there's a study that came out in April
of this year from Mitchell Mitchell lang
Bert associate professor of business
management at Brooklyn College and the
study is from the National Association
of scholars it compared the number of
democratic faculty for every Republican
in 25 academic fields there was a sample
size of over 5,000 professors so guess
which majors were the least politically
biased in terms of the breakdown all the
ones that earn all the ones that earn
among engineering professors there were
1.6 Democrats for every Republican you
think oh well that's it that's a 60%
imbalance I mean that seems on that that
seems like a pretty major imbalance that
is the lowest level of imbalance among
any major is 1.6 Democrats to every
Republican mainly because a lot of
Democrats like to go into the education
field also because it's this sort of
ivory tower mentality where everybody
agrees with one another at these
universities but that's not supremely
imbalanced 1.6 Democrats for ever a
Republican in engineering right again
which is the highest earning major among
chemistry professors 5.2 Democrats for
every Republican economics professors
5.5 Democrats for every Republican
professionals 5.5 mathematics 5.6 in
other words all of the hard core majors
where you learn something and increase
your income trajectory you're
subsidizing actual marketable
commodities not leftist professors now
here's the imbalance in the useless
majors as I like to call them the major
is in lesbian dance theory and sociology
hey here are the professor imbalances in
these particular fields among liberal
arts professors for communications
degrees 108 Democrats in communications
compared with 0 Republicans 56 to 0 in
anthropology 70 to 1 in theology forty
eight to forty eight point three to one
in English forty three point eight to
one in sociology forty point three to
one and our in other words this is
Democrats subsidizing a bunch of majors
that are not marketable with your
taxpayer dollars in order to keep all
their friends employed and in order to
shovel people into a university system
that pushes their political values
that's what we're talking about it's
when you see people in the middle of the
country who like Mike Rowe for example
and work jobs that don't require a
college degree and they look with scorn
on all of the educational pretensions of
the highfalutin left maybe the reason
they're angry is because their taxpayer
dollars are being sucked out of their
pocket to be
used as political cuddles on behalf of
an entrenched interest group at the
university level when people complain
about the elites these are the people
that they are talking about these are
the folks they're talking about I want
to talk a little bit more about
corruption in statistics in just one
second but first let's talk about how
you make your resume better and I'm not
talking about with the useless college
degree and lesbian dance Theory I'm
talking about actual skills this is why
you need skill share skill share is an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
in social media marketing illustration
data science mobile photography creative
writing you name it they've got it
you can make your skillset better which
of course is what you actually want in a
free market economy whether you're
trying to deepen that professional skill
center start a side hustle or explore
new passions Skillshare is for you these
are like 45-minute classes with actual
experts you get feedback from them it
really is tremendous I've taken classes
in social media marketing and
watercolours because I like to diversify
my educational knowledge go check out
skills show right now join the millions
of students already learning get two
months of Skillshare for just 99 cents
again Skillshare offering ben shapiro
show listeners two months of unlimited
access to over 20,000 classes for just
99 cents to sign up go to Skillshare
comm slash Shapiro that skill shared
comm slash appear to start that two
months right now when you get that
subscription you get 99 cents night for
99 cents you get two months of
Skillshare check it out right now
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro go broaden
your skill set broaden your horizons
make your resume more marketable okay so
I want to talk about skewed statistics
in other arenas of American life in just
one second but first you're gonna have
to go over to daily wire comm so when
you go over to daily wire comm you're
gonna get the rest of the show live the
rest of mandrel clave ins show live the
rest of Michael Noel's new show live you
get to be part of the mailbag which we
are doing tomorrow there's a short week
for May but it was a long week for you
so I'll add so I'll answer all your
questions tomorrow also
when we do the conversation which I
believe is coming up on on Friday right
I mean are we doing the conversation
tomorrow yes we know that it's the
following Friday it's a week from Friday
we're doing the conversation when we do
that then you're gonna be able to ask
your questions and get all your
questions answered by me if you are a
member so go check it out right now over
at daily wire comm
when you get the annual subscription you
get this the very greatest in beverage
vessels the left is tears hot or cold
tumblr you will enjoy it you'll enjoy it
the conversation is tomorrow Senya we're
going to be using we're
to be using our our zip recruiter to to
replace Anya because of that error in
just one saying but if you want the
actual leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler refilling daily go check it out
right now ninety-nine dollars a year
also go check out our YouTube make sure
you check out our YouTube and our
SoundCloud and when you do check that
out you will get the Sunday special
which this week feature is the
inimitable and insane steven crowder so
check that out this Sunday it's a lot of
fun and also there's unexpected depth
from steven crowder i think so
you're gonna want to go check that out
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk about some
other skewed statistics the other day I
was reading about the this long piece in
The New York Times Magazine about people
who are living in poverty in the United
States the basic suggestion being there
is not enough of a social safety net in
the United States the United States
spends an insane amount of money on our
social safety net on a per capita basis
we do spend as much as European
countries on our social safety net we
spend an enormous quantity of cash on
Social Security and Medicaid and
Medicare and food stamps and all the
rest of these social welfare programs
but according to matthew desmond who's
the author of a book called evicted he
wanted to Pulitzer Prize in 2017 for it
basically having a job isn't enough in
the United States the way that he gets
to this answer is by playing with the
stats again this just demonstrates again
and again that elites in American
society are willing to manipulate the
stats in what I think is corrupt fashion
in order to reach preordained political
conclusions and that's for whether
you're looking at college stats that is
true certainly when you are looking at
Google search results and it is it is
also true when it comes to public policy
issues Kevin Williamson has a great
break down over at National Review of
this piece he talks about the the fact
that when Democrats say that having a
job in the United States is useless that
is eminently untrue here's what Kevin
Williamson writes according to matthew
desmond he tells the story of vanessa
sullivan and her three children in their
economic struggles sullivan is a home
health aide a job for which she has paid
between 10 bucks and fourteen bucks an
hour depending on the reimbursement rate
of the patient in question she works
part-time between 20 and 30 hours a week
desmond writes the federal government
estimates sullivan would need to earn
twenty nine thousand four hundred twenty
bucks to meet her family's basic needs
this is written under the headline
americans want to believe jobs are the
solution to poverty they're not and
Kevin Winston says well aren't they if
we assume an average wage of twelve
bucks an hour in the middle of that $10
to 14 an hour spread then Sullivan would
were $24,000 a year by working 40 hours
a week 50 weeks a year which is what
most people work I mean we at this
office work that pretty much every year
as Desmond notes our welfare programs
favor the employed and as such Solomon
would receive about 5,200 bucks in
Earned Income Tax Credit benefits
raising her total income absent any
other benefits to twenty nine thousand
two hundred bucks just a few dollars shy
of that twenty
thousand four hundred $20 estimate of
her family's basic needs which is to say
a job looks like a pretty good solution
if not a complete solution to poverty in
her case provided it's an actual
full-time job so perhaps the headline
should be amended part-time jobs are not
a solution to poverty but that isn't
much of a headline since not many people
believe that part-time jobs are such a
solution it will occur to some that you
that the fathers of Sullivan's three
children are out of the picture for the
most part one of them is dead of a
gunshot wound after a stint in prison
the others contributed to his children's
welfare has been erratic child support
payments in a single trip to
chuck-e-cheeses as Desmond reports what
if they learnt the case to $12 an hour
workers married say working full-time
jobs bringing about 48 grand a year or
about 40% more than the medium how
median household income in Trenton New
Jersey or Sullivan lives
so maybe the headline instead should be
amended to read having two full-time
earners in a household is actually a
pretty good solution to poverty or if we
want to get radical marriage and
full-time employment together are a
pretty good solution to poverty Desmond
gets that he reports that solvin and
many others like her would prefer to
work more hours than they do but for
many reasons they cannot he does not
consider very carefully why that is it
is difficult to look at Sullivan's
situation and see a problem that is
primarily economic in nature the wage on
offer would given different family
circumstances be sufficient to raise her
and her children out of poverty even in
a low-skilled low pay job of course
having two parents working full-time
with three children puts all sorts of
stress on family life having both of
them working one as the secretary wanted
it one as a janitor to high school with
four children certainly did it would
still be a tough life but to return to a
familiar theme we must ask compared to
what there are all sorts of things to be
said in debate to be had about welfare
benefits taxes education different
treatment of income investment and wage
income etc but does anyone really think
that rearranging any of that is going to
produce a world in which a part-time
Home Health Aide raising three children
in New Jersey is not going to have a
hard time friends did anybody listen
when conservatives were pointing out
that the structure of the Affordable
Care Act would give employers incentives
to prefer part-time workers to full-time
workers or when your correspondent
argued that federal and local policies
intended to keep the price of houses
high and rising inevitably are going to
be hard on the poor or when social
conservatives pointed to the obvious
link between single motherhood and
poverty there are a million things we
can and should be doing differently when
it comes to helping people such as
Vanessa Sullivan and her children writes
Kevin Williamson but if anything
her case should point us toward exactly
the kind of reforms conservatives have
been arguing for those that are oriented
toward work and eventual
self-sufficiency and those oriented
toward the much trickier business of
trying to encourage the formation and
preservation of intact families which
more and more seems to me to be the root
of much of the dysfunction under
consideration and the reason I read at
length from Williamson's column is again
the left has a particular set of values
they want to push those values by using
government largesse and by lying about
the stats that is true whether you're
talking free college or whether you're
talking welfare programs and it is a
huge mistake to take all of that at face
value instead you actually have to delve
into the statistics to realize that
there are entrenched political interests
that are at the root of a lot of these
problems and what Democrats are doing in
many cases is simply serving those
entrenched political interests now
meanwhile I know that you remember when
everybody on the Left was accusing
President Trump of Russian collusion
mainly because they still are and it
turns out that the molar investigation
is seems to sort of be falling apart in
a lot of ways George papadopolis who
suppose whose mail activity supposedly
led to the launch of the Muller
investigation he was recently sentenced
for lying to the FBI got 14 days in jail
which suggests they really didn't have a
lot on George papadopolis
and then it turns out that the Russian
honeypot you know that the accusation
was that there was this Russian woman
who was going around honeypot in
particular Republicans in order to get
access on behalf of the Russian
government it turns out she wasn't
actually doing that so they still have
her in jail on other charges but a lot
of this looks a lot like battery and
unless they come out with some sort of
clear and convincing evidence of actual
Russian interference in the election at
the behest of the Trump campaign it's
gonna be very difficult to make that
case there are those of us on the right
who have said let's wait for all the
evidence to come out I am happy to wait
for all the evidence to come out but I
don't have to wait for the evidence to
come out when it comes to actual
democratic collusion with foreign
governments the evidence this week of
governments comes courtesy of drawing
power
remember draw our worst Secretary of
State in American history yes worse than
Hillary Clinton an absolute crap show of
a Secretary of State guy who helped
negotiated the lies and in
prevarications of the Iran deal which
put Iran on the direct path toward a
nuclear bomb without any sort of
international disapproval so secretary
Kerry has a long stand
relationship with javad zarif who is the
Foreign Minister for Iran it goes all
the way back before he was Secretary of
State this is like a decade before
apparently he knew javad zarif according
to a book by whom on majd who frequently
translates for Iranian officials so
here's a long-standing relationship with
a lot of Iranian foreign officials and
he's been advocating since 2004 doing
some sort of deal with the Iranian so
he's obviously got a personal stake in
all of this and he also is pursuing his
own foreign policy on the side he went
over to Iran and chatted with the moas
and there he basically made a promise to
them which is wait until a democratic
administration and then we'll get all of
this straightened out it's kind of
amazing how hypocritical it is for
Democrats to engage in this sort of
collusion on a regular basis and for no
one to care Barack Obama was caught in a
hot mic in 2012 saying to Dmitry
Medvedev who is then the deputy to
Vladimir Putin that if that if the
Russians would lay off you would give
them flexibility after the election and
no one on the Left gave a crap now it's
John Kerry saying the same things the
Iranian government and still no one on
the Left gives a crap here's John Kerry
talking about his shadow diplomacy every
Secretary of State former Secretary of
State continues to meet with foreign
leaders ghost security security
conferences goes around the world we all
do that and we have conversations with
people about the state of affairs in the
world in order to understand them I
think everybody in the world is sitting
around talking about waiting out the
president from John Kerry is indeed
incredibly connected with the Iranian
government he likes the Iranian
government and it is ridiculous to
suggest that past secretaries of state
were traveling abroad to make separate
foreign policy on behalf of future
administration's that's not accurate
John Kerry was grilled on this by Dana
Perino yesterday on Fox News he had no
good answers for it the Trump
administration would be frustrated to
learn that a former Secretary of State
or former official T Obama
administration are advising the Iranians
or the Europeans on this even if it's
contrary let me let me be crystal clear
when I met with the Iranians the policy
of the United States was still to be in
the Iran deal because President had not
decided not pulled out
secondly every Secretary of State former
Secretary of State continues to meet
with foreign leaders ghost security
security conferences goes around the
world we all do that ok no you don't all
go around the world negotiating separate
deals with terrorists governments that's
not something that happens this is open
collusion okay it's not even closeted
collusion at this point it's open
collusion between Democrats and an enemy
government to the United States and
we're supposed to just take that as
though that's normal
we're supposed to pretend that all of
that is fine you know III hesitate to
use this is how you got Trump but kinda
it is I mean when you just violate every
rule then suggest that people on the
other side are violating rules it makes
everybody so cynical about politics they
say just give us anybody who's not lying
to us no matter how crass they are no
matter what silly things they say John
Kerry is a garbage human he's been a
garbage human his entire career and the
fact that he is still going around
negotiating deals with an evil terror
state his demonstration of that once
more okay time for some things I like
and then some things I hate so things I
like in the aftermath of the stabbing of
a main line Brazilian political
candidate on the right I've been reading
some books about Brazil cuz I want to
get more educated on the topic there's a
good book by a guy named Larry Rohr who
I believe used to write for Newsweek
called Brazil on the rise it requires an
update since like 2010 but it's a good
explanation of Brazil's culture and its
politics
suffice it to say that Brazil has been
rife with governmental corruption for an
awful long period of time and since 2010
when this book was published it was
taken over by radical leftists like
Dilma Rousseff who was then now stood
for corruption and her deputy took over
and now Brazil is in the midst of a very
very contentious election Brazil does
not have an actual right-wing party in
the American Conservative sense of a
right-wing party they have more
nationalist parties that are somewhat
more free-market economically but Brazil
has been a chaotic place politically
thanks to not only its history but
thanks to a legacy of socialist
governments that stretches back to the
the death of the dictatorship in the
1980s and it's worth reading about
Brazil because Brazil has always been
considered a country with enormous
economic potential the only way that
potential is really going to be
unleashed on a major scale is if Brazil
which has friendly relations with all of
its neighbors results has
enormous Natural Resources as if Brazil
begins to take seriously the injunctions
of the American Constitution and take
seriously economic Liberty and personal
property rights instead of the the quasi
socialist policies that have corrupted
its government for decades and decades
and decades at this point okay time for
some things that I hate so Planned
Parenthood has a new president the new
president is Leanna when and she has now
cut a video on behalf of Planned
Parenthood and this video demonstrates
full scale how conflicting ridiculous
morally bereft Planned Parenthood's
actual mission is and I want to fight
for our most vulnerable individuals on a
bigger scale and that's why it became
the health commissioner of Baltimore I
see what's at stake those will be hurt
the most
are those who already bear the brunt of
health disparities they are women of low
income of color she wants to help the
most vulnerable you understand she wants
help the most vulnerable the most
vulnerable no not the babies inside the
women let's not do that we're talking
about poor women who have to kill babies
in order so they can get ahead
economically that's obviously the issue
here it's it's pretty amazing stuff when
honestly firfer when to be as
pro-abortion each is pretty astonishing
considering she came from China with her
parents when she was 8 years old
she said her family was dependent on
Medicaid and food stamps and also on
Planned Parenthood for health care and
then she says she became an ER doctor
because she never wanted to turn any
patients away presumably now she wants
to help fund the the killing of babies
it is worth noting that the China that
she came from and that her parents
escaped had a one-child policy for
legitimately decades that ended with the
murder particularly of young of unborn
the the forced abortion of unborn
Chinese females which is why there is a
massive imbalance between the number of
males and females in Chinese society
that actually leads to some geopolitical
instability the fact that Planned
Parenthood is constantly tweeting about
about how we have to protect the most
vulnerable just demonstrates how
inhumane Planned Parenthood is they
don't even recognize the life of the of
the child inside and of course they can
because if they did they couldn't do
what does they do on a rag on a regular
basis meanwhile other things that I hate
so Michael Moore and and the left have
become increasingly unhinged one thing
that I didn't like during the last
election cycle
a lot of folks on the right is this is
the last election if Hillary Clinton
wins this is the last election there
will ever be the country is at stake
if we elect Hillary Clinton the country
will end now I think there's a strong
case you made against Hillary Clinton as
president for sure I disagreed with her
on virtually 100% of her policies but it
was not gonna be the last election hey
America is a pretty durable place our
Constitution is pretty durable shoot had
a Republican Congress that doesn't mean
she should have been elected president I
never at any point encouraged people to
vote for Hillary Clinton but I also
thought it was ridiculous for people to
suggest this is gonna be the last
election Democrats are now doing the
same thing with Trump they say basically
Trump could be the end of the country as
we know it this sort of extreme rhetoric
does increase the temperature in
American politics makes it less likely
that we actually are going to have a
social fabric to return to when all of
this chaos is through here's Michael
Moore making the case that Trump could
be the last president do you think that
last president United States it's
possible you really think that I think
it's possible absolutely I think that we
have someone in the White House who has
no respect for the rule of law who
dislikes democracy by an incredible
degree which doesn't make him really any
that much different from other
billionaires or CEOs because their
businesses are not democracies they rule
by Fiat they decide they make the call
so they don't like having anybody else
having a say yeah that's that's it I
mean if you really believe that the the
administration in power is gonna thwart
democracy itself then you do have a duty
to go get a gun at this point Michael
Moore is pretty anti-gun has the duty to
pick up a gun if he actually thinks that
democracy is about to be thwarted and
the tyrannical institution is about to
be in it created at the top of American
government they'll end elections doesn't
he sort of have a duty to put together
an army you would think but he doesn't
actually nobody actually believes this
including stupid Michael Moore and he's
not the only one Joy Behar who continues
to mouth off in braying ass fashion she
suggests that she basically suggests
that Donald Trump should die which is
just a wonderful thing to send on
mainstream American television if he
lives another twenty years ago I would
not judge if
he could be like 105 by the time he you
know we've got him here for the next
okay so just well done there joy behar
god forbid he lives in nother 20 years
when you wish death on your political
opponents that's usually a bad that's
usually a bad sign and then you wonder
why it is that so much of American
politics is is above and beyond the norm
you can't blame at all on Trump join
bears been around quite a while and
she's been saying stuff like this for a
long time okay we'll be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest
including the updates on the hurricane
and all the rest i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire Ford publishing
production copyright Ford publishing